I don't want to be shame.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
the fifth chapter, the chapter of
vigilance of Allah's observation
authored by
we're in the third narration in that
chapter. The narration
of Ib Abbass.
Ib Abbass. His name is
Abdullah and his
Abbas.
And he
he was born which year?
[Arabic recitation]
Ninth. Yeah. Yeah. Right. 9th
8th 9th 10th before hij correct. And he
passed away which year?
58. Correct.
the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
was riding with Abbas behind him once
and he said,
"Young boy,
I'm going to teach you some beliefs,
some statements, some truisms.
Preserve Allah in his boundaries and he
will preserve you. Preserve
Allah and his boundaries. Preserve his
boundaries. Preserve his prohibitions
and Allah and you will find him in front
of you.
If you ask, then ask Allah.
And if you seek aid, seek aid in Allah.
And know, be certain
that if all of the world, all of mankind
were to collaborate,
to attempt to benefit you with
something, they would not be able to
benefit you except with that which Allah
has already written for you.
And
similarly, if they were to collaborate,
to attempt to harm you with something,
they will only be able to harm you with
that which Allah has written upon you.
The pens of decree have been lifted off
the pages and the ink has dried. If we
were to embrace this belief here in
America, 95% of all lawsuits would be
dropped immediately.
Immediately. Because the American way is
some human being is at fault somewhere
somehow someway. My coffee was too hot.
They should have written it on the car.
That's why I got burnt. I didn't get
burnt because I was a klutz. I didn't
get burnt because I was trying to do
five things in my car at once. I got
burnt because it didn't say that my
coffee was hot. I was expecting it to be
ice cold. Right? As if when people
receive their cup of coffee, they stop
and read the instructions. This is the
kind of culture that we start to develop
when we start to have a lack of belief
in the decree of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. There's a medium. There is a
medium, a a middle path. Does it mean no
one's at fault ever? No. That's not
true.
When someone is obviously at fault, they
should be held accountable. However,
this idea that humanity has got things
under control. So much so that if
everyone did exactly what they were
supposed to, nothing bad could ever
happen. This is a disease. Humanity is
not in control of this ship. We are not
in control of this planet. We are in
control of our direct actions or
inactions. Those are the things which we
are to be held accountable for or not.
outside of that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala decrees
what is to be and no amount of
collaboration
no amount of warning labels no amount of
vigilance no amount of caution will
prevent what Allah has decreed and
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
says this as much in in another
narration collected by
in his in his
narrates
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said,
"Take this to heart. Add this
add this truism
to these. add this idiom to these. He
says,
he says, "No amount of vigilance will
stop the decree of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala."
Notice the wording here. No amount of
vigilance will stop the decree.
It didn't say no amount of vigilance
will stop what a person is being
vigilant of. That's a different thing.
Locking your doors will most likely keep
out bandits. However, if Allah has
decreed for those bandits to be inside
your home, there is no amount of locks
or safes, there's no amount of in
infrastructure that will protect your
home from that. If Allah has decreed it,
it will be. If Allah has decreed the sky
not to rain, it will never rain. There
is no hand
mighty enough to reach into the sky and
change Allah's decree. If Allah has
decreed that rain be unceasing, there is
no hand that will reach into the sky and
stop its stop its rainfall.
The prophet tells us sallallahu alaihi
wasallam the pens have been lifted
and the pages are and the pages are
dried. The ink has dried
and so this is
not just
this is not just placing things where
they in their rightful place. This is
not just a belief system to protect us
from each other, but it's a belief
system that is liberating.
Isn't it liberating? You don't have to
be guilty about things that you don't
have to take on guilt that doesn't
belong to you. I don't have to take on
guilt that doesn't belong to me. There
are things that Allah has decreed to
happen and they will happen. There's no
amount of vigilance that will stop it.
We are to be vigilant of our own
actions, not of Allah's decree.
inaction, not of Allah's decree. But if
something happens, we know at that
moment that Allah has decreed it. If
Allah hadn't decreed it, it would not
have happened. And this is why our
prophet teaches us that.
He says, "And do not say
to anything that has afflicted you, if
only I had done such and such, the
result would have been different."
Rather say, "It is Allah's decree and
what he has willed, he has done." Make
this your motto. Don't just say it as
lip service.
Don't just say it with your tongue while
your heart is furious at the decree of
Allah. No, no, no.
Chant this.
Chant it.
Do you know how the companions used to
teach themselves acceptance
of these difficult beliefs sometimes?
I will tell you a story. This story is
in Muslim.
Abu narrates that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala sent down a verse
that was as painful as iron to some of
the companions when it was sent down.
Allah Subhanahu Wa'ta'ala sent down the
verse.
Allah says,
"And to Allah belongs that which is in
the heavens and that which is in the
earths.
And if you were to conceal what is in
your hearts or manifest it, Allah knows
it all the same.
If you were to manifest what's in your
heart or conceal it, Allah knows it
equally and just the same. And he will
hence
punish whom he chooses and forgive whom
he chooses
and Allah is able to do all things. What
are the implications of this verse?
The implications of this verse
is that anything that goes through our
heart, we are held to account for.
Any good, any bad,
any bad thing
that
passes through our heart, even a
fleeting thought that we're not in
control of, right? Every one of us. It
takes years and years of discipline to
be able to control the thoughts to the
point where you know to limit I can't
even say to completely cease but to
limit
any fleeting bad thought to go through
your mind. But the implications of this
verse is that everything that goes
through your mind,
you are accountable for.
If it is sinful, you are sinful and
Allah will then forgive or overlooked
for whom he chooses and Allah is able to
do all things. Abu said the companions
came to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
upon learning this verse.
And they fell literally on their knees
and figuratively in front of him. And
they said,
[Silence]
He they said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
Allah has commanded us with prayer." And
so we prayed. He commanded us to give
charity and we gave. And he commanded us
to fight in jihad and we fought. But
this we're unable to we're unable to
handle it. It's too much. It's more
than we can bear.
And so the prophet sallall.aii was said
to the companions, listen to what he
said. He said,
He said, "Are you saying
like
said to their messenger, we hear and we
disobey? Is that what you're saying to
me?"
He said, "Don't say that.
rather say, "We hear and we obey.
Our Lord, we beg of you your
forgiveness, and to you is our
inevitable return."
And so the companions,
what did they learn here? They learned,
they learned how to submit themselves to
Allah entirely.
that what what are you going to do?
That's what the king has said. Are you
going to say no? What are you gonna say?
And so what did they learn here? They
were taught by the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. Instead of saying we
hear and we disobey, we we hear and we
reject. We hear and we obey.
And what we are unable to do in
obedience, we beg of you, your
forgiveness. and pardon and to you is
our inevitable return. Abu Huray said in
the coming days after this interaction,
the companions started to chant this to
themselves everywhere they were in
Medina. Anywhere you'd go in Medina,
you'd hear the buzzing of the Muslim
teaching themselves forcefully.
Why? Because nowan is whispering. Now
their nephs is fighting is fighting
back. It's fighting the medicine. And
they are countering this with what? With
the medicine. The prophet gave you the
medicine. You have to take it. And so
wherever you would go in Medina in those
following days, you would hear the
companions
buzzing with the chant of this mantra.
He said until their hearts accepted it
and until they embraced it then Allah
sent down the remaining two verses of al
Bakar in which Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
said taught us to
taught us the dua
And Allah sent down this dua
and said,
"Anyone who makes this dua, I
I have I have answered with
positive This is how the companions
taught themselves. They didn't twist
words.
They didn't accommodate.
They didn't try to , you know, trim a
little bit here and there off, right?
They didn't explain it with
explanations that suit them. That's what
Allah said.
And so they taught themselves these
things. How do we teach oursel these
these things? Because there's a big
difference between learning the
statement and believing the statement.
We continue to fight our demons with
these statements until our hearts
finally accept them and have conviction.
Then and only then will we be freed from
the clutches of our own ignorance and
the plots and devices of a shaitan.
going to be in a Muhammad.